[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
cette exposition est née de la volonté
de marquer les 10 ans de la loi du grand
paris puisqu'il ya dix ans la loi du
grand paris a lancé le projet de cluster
scientifique technologique et
technologique de paris saclay
l'établissement public a souhaité
marquer le coup en choeur en événements
et on sait on s'est beaucoup interrogé
sur la manière de faire et finalement on
a décidé qu'il pouvait être intéressant
de faire un pas de côté un peu par
rapport à notre métier d'aménageur et de
et de réfléchir à comment on pouvait
montrer ce territoire d'une manière
différente notamment avec des regards un
peu un peu décalé et doué d de là est
venue l'idée de faire cette exposition
et puis on a voulu également que cette
exposition soit itinérante
c'était très important pour nous que
cette exposition puisse aller à la
rencontre des habitants et des usagers
des territoires et c'est pour ça qu'on a
aujourd'hui on est on est à gif sur
yvette et que cette exposition va se
déplacer à guyancourt à versailles sur
le campus urbain pour aller à la
rencontre des habitants
[Musique]
cette exposition paris saclay est un
projet audacieux dans lequel s'est lancé
le pea nous sommes très fiers d'être la
première ville à recevoir cette
exposition elle permet de découvrir
paris saclay sous un autre angle et de
réconcilier si besoin l'aviation caylar
le paysage permet d'illustrer la
dynamique du territoire ainsi on peut
identifier les différents types de
population les paysages variés de notre
territoire ainsi que les styles
architecturaux
le château du val fleuri était une
demeure du ceva la ville ensuite acquis
cette propriété donc c'est un peu une
suite logique aujourd'hui de recevoir
cette exposition et en plus ça d'être
les premiers à la recevoir
[Musique]